Hey what's up guys. Grant Thompson. I'm back
with Ritchie and Jake. They are the crew from
the SonicDad team. I will put a link in
the description so you can check out
their videos. They got some pretty cool
stuff. These guys invented a mini
marshmallow cannon that we upgraded to
one of these giant alcohol powered
rocket launcher. So a couple of weeks ago we
took this mini marshmallow cannon and we've
doubled the size into this monstrosity
here. These things turned out a lot more
powerful than we expected and we ask you
what kind of things you want us to shoot
out of them and Blazing Inferno left the
comment asking us to make some kind of
exploding ammunition so I got together with
this guy Ritchie and we spent yesterday
packing 30 or 40 of these many missiles
These little shells are designed to shoot out
of the alcohol cannon. They have a pistol primer
to ignite the powder charge inside. At
this stage, it's is in the safe condition
until I add this little pin which is
what is designed to hit the primer. Now
it's armed and ready to go
warhead is active haha
with the nail inside once these things
are shot. It will orient itself, nose
first and when it makes impact with the hard
surface it's going to blow up or at
least that's the idea. Wow, it was a
little more powerful than i was
expecting and I saw the tail flied all the way up to here
way up to here. Yeah, my ears're ringing. Hahahaha
that's awesome check this out
so you can see all the different layers that
Ritchie 3d printed here to give it some
stability it looks like it just blasted
the two apart so that's probably because
of my hot gluing job if i did a little better job we
might've got this whole thing to explode but it's
still pretty loud
very impressive I think we got some
ammunition to work with so let's load them up and fire them up
I should've probably been wearing my glasses
for that
let's go shoot some missiles now that we
know these things work we need a cool
target to shoot at some stuff by the
supercenter and picked up some kitty
litter as well as a colorful donkey
pinata let's go have some fun
hopefully that just makes it a little
more stable
we named our pinata Jack one of your
baby powder around so let's pump the sink
ready
he oh he oh this is where it gets real
You call it Ritchie. Two one fire wow haha oh my lifted
off the rock. Check this out check this out. It's
actually on fire
it's smoking and you can actually feel
like layers of paper burning away
they're going to go out huh burned my
finger right here is definitely one to
get back we had one in fact it's not
that in mind I feel like I was a little
high but we had a couple of good shots
down here and definitely somebody slips
right here you know what let's load up
and hit him again before he burns to the
ground is ready
it's a really hard shot to hit that pinata
it is wedged in there this thing smoking at
the top there's a chance he could blow
up but it's active kitty litter that is
crazy
oh he's bleeding, he is bleeding kitty litter
all that stuff that loaded with more
missile ok i got you one more that was
awesome
So update guys we are down to our last few
rounds so we started these things as
best we can
we're gonna take one final shot and see
what kind of damage we can do at the end of the day.
You guys ready? READY!
FIRE!
That was the money shot! Right there.
I told you were going down.
Perfect! Let's go take a look. Look at this
look up inside the neck here we've actually
got a warhead gone on that is why we
always check after we shot because we
have a live warhead in there and I bet
we still have a live warhead buried in
here as well we found one that didn't go
off them to get a handbomb it against that
wall
oh yeah that was is the stuff. That was amazing
I'm really glad we did this today there
you have it guys looks like are
exploding missile darks work after all
super big thanks to blazing Inferno for
suggesting this comment
check your inbox i'm sending you 25 bucks
Big Thanks to Jake and Richie from SonicDad.com
for helping me build these cannons
and launch these missiles today i'll put a
link in the description for their mini
marshmallow cannon you could build a
smaller version of these and have some
fun at home it's been awesome hang out
with you in this video we'll be looking
for the next one talk you then. Hit it!
gonna blow up at least that's the idea